m
jean d'aurec a fait son choix il sera
boulanger boulangère métier dont il
devra faire l'apprentissage en métropole
dans l'un des magasins du groupe casino
ils s'envolent d'ici quelques jours pour
parfaire sa formation avec le soutien de
son père plutôt motivé pas les femmes a
pas moins sûr et pas des gens là-bas en
boulangerie rapport mcchrystal
j'ai fait pendant nos stages sont
excusés et dérision oui c'est la pause à
l'idée partir le diplôme qui a réussi à
vraiment très très difficile
depuis cinq ans le canard non
partenariat avec le groupe vindémia
permet à des jeunes réunionnais en
difficulté de s'insérer
professionnellement par l'intermédiaire
de contrats d'apprentissage ou de
perfectionnement en termes de
responsabilité sociale est essentiel de
pouvoir envoyer des jeunes chez land au
magasin géant un supermarché dans la
restauration pour apprendre un métier
périlleux rythme comme la boucherie la
poissonnerie etc c'est quelque chose
essentielle parce qu'à un moment donné
on a toujours besoin de ce type de
métier c'est bien de prendre notre
responsabilité donc de les former et
peut-être un jour d'aller voir revenir
chef de rayon dans un magasin ils
étaient plus de 90 et à la fin il n'en
restera qu'une vingtaine à l'issue de la
sélection des jeunes très motivés donc à
l'image d'angélique une poissonnière qui
exerce sa passion depuis maintenant cinq
ans je pars parce que pour aline un
diplôme en fait parce qu'ici à la
réunion la formation n'existe pas est ce
qu'il te plaît partie commence de dans
ce métier le métier ennuis et puis il ya
anthony qui a pris les recherches
infructueuses dans le département voir
l'opportunité de partir à un contrat
d'apprentissage
une véritable chance d'apprendre un
métier pour enfin trouver du travail
une idée qu'il partage avec sa mère car
les mots
avant toute chose de bien je pense que
c'est obligé il est non seulement je
suis très content ici à la réunion c'est
saturé il n'y a pas de débouchés
c'est là une des solutions conçoit sans
avenir surtout chez les jeunes qui est
quand même assez confiant très et c'est
dans les locaux du magasin de sens marie
que tous les futurs apprentis se sont
vus remettre leurs promesses dans moche
dans divers métiers de bouche
ces jeunes bénéficient d'un
accompagnement du cnam une structure
financée par le conseil départemental
sans le conseil départemental le cnam
n'existerait pas et j'ai rappelé aux
jeunes qui partent et que grâce à la
volonté politique du conseil
départemental
le dispositif d'accompagnement qui leur
était offert était exceptionnel unique
en métropole et que en plus la manière
dont nous gérons tout cela fait que un
départ revient en moyenne à 5000 euros à
la puissance publique ce qui fait de ce
départ et de cette ouverture vers un
vrai emploi une vraie formation un des
couples les moins élevés en matière
d'emploi j'aime beaucoup la restauration
est comme un vol vers détente et profits
c'est une chance qu'il y allait avoir
fait ma touche principe est là qu est ce
qu elle veut se qualifier de la langue
et de cette fois qu'elle prend sa ronde
qu'elle prend son envol tout seul génial
bouchers poissonniers boulanger depuis
2010 ce sont 56 réunionnais qui ont été
recrutés dans le cadre de ce partenariat
entre le club et le groupe vindémia